Salut, moi, c'est Guillaume Hachez. Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec. Avec ce podcast, j'essaie de toucher à toutes sortes de sujets de société, y compris souvent des sujets que je ne maîtrise pas du tout.
On a pu par exemple parler de neurobiologie avec le professeur Jacques Balthazart,
de féminisme avec Olivia Gazalé, de l'utilisation des réseaux sociaux par le mouvement national populiste avec Giuliano Da Empoli, mais on n'a encore jamais vraiment parlé d'économie.
Et c'est très étrange parce qu'il ne vous aura pas échappé que ces temps-ci, on ne fait que parler de la crise climatique, de transition écologique, des gilets jaunes, de Trump.
Bref, il était grand temps qu'on reçoive dans cette émission un grand expert pour tirer tout ça au clair. Je reçois aujourd'hui Bruno Colmant.
Bruno Colmant est CEO de la banque de placement Degroof Petercam et membre de l'Académie royale. Il enseigne la finance dans plusieurs grandes universités belges.
Il préside le Belgian Finance Club. Il dirigeait autrefois la Bourse de Bruxelles et il a aussi publié plus de cinquante ouvrages.
Bref, mon invité est quelqu'un d'extrêmement productif et de très intelligent et je suis très heureux de le recevoir aujourd'hui.
Deux petites précisions avant de se lancer dans l'interview. D'abord, c'est un épisode qui est plus court que d'habitude.
Monsieur Colmant avait des affaires pressantes à gérer, mais la bonne nouvelle, c'est qu'il est assez dense et qu'on aborde tout de même de nombreuses questions.
Et enfin, je vous rappelle que l'économie est une science située et qu'en conséquence, forcément, vous pourrez très certainement trouver un ou une économiste qui pense tout le contraire de ce que dit monsieur Colmant.
Et je vous invite donc à prendre, comme souvent, un peu de recul en écoutant ce qui est dit. Mais dans tous les cas, lui comme moi, on espère très fort que l'écoute de cet entretien pourra nourrir chez vous une réflexion sur toutes ces questions.
C'est parti. J'ai aujourd'hui le plaisir d'être avec monsieur Bruno Colmant. Bruno Colmant, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Alors, je sais qu'on vous le dit souvent, mais vous frappez en général par votre capacité à ne pas être enfermé dans des canevas idéologiques traditionnels, à vous élever au-dessus de la mêlée.
Vous êtes un économiste de droite qui cite Karl Marx. Vous êtes pro-Europe, mais vous regrettez la monnaie unique. Vous enseignez à l'ULB et à l'UCL et je pourrais continuer longtemps comme ça.
Alors, tout d'abord, est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec cette description, une personne qui échappe au canevas traditionnel ?
Et deuxièmement, comment est-ce que vous expliquez cette capacité ?
Ben, j'ai choisi depuis très longtemps, dans ma carrière, de l'avoir polymorphe, d'avoir une carrière d'abord académique, mais aussi professionnelle.
Et en fait, une partie de mon temps libre est consacrée à l'écriture. Et cette quête, dans l'écriture, c'est plutôt la recherche de visions différentes,
d'être un observateur attentif d'évolutions sous des angles parfois un tout petit peu inattendus.
Et j'ai jamais eu envie d'être embarrassé d'un cadre, dont j'aurais été affublé.
Donc, j'essaie d'avoir un esprit libre. C'est finalement ce que j'ai appris à l'ULB. J'ai appris à l'ULB
la vision pragmatique et surtout inductive des choses et j'essaie de la transposer dans mon activité professionnelle et académique.
Et donc, l'exemple qui frappe dans ce que j'ai listé, c'est notamment le fait que vous enseignez. Donc, on parlait de l'ULB, mais également à l'UCL, mais aussi à Vlerick, à Saint-Louis et ainsi de suite.
L'économie est une science située, a une composante idéologique en soi. Comment est-ce que vous expliquez que vous soyez capable de-
D'abord, je n'enseigne pas l'économie en tant que telle. J'enseigne ce qu'on appelle l'histoire de la comptabilité, la comptabilité financière, la finance de marché, la finance d'entreprise.
Donc, ce sont des matières relativement objectives. Et j'y ai consacré mon doctorat à l'ULB il y a une vingtaine d'années.
J'ai choisi finalement de donner cours dans plusieurs universités par souci de ne pas dépendre d'une seule
et avec la conviction de pouvoir disperser un savoir et avoir surtout des interactions de la part des étudiants venant de différents contextes.
Donc c'est vrai que la réaction à un même cours d'étudiants de l'ULB, d'UCL ou de Vlerick est différente, c'est enrichissant pour eux, pour moi.
Et voilà comment j'ai choisi de disperser ma vie académique. Mais au-delà de ça, y a la passion de l'écriture, la passion de l'enseignement qui m'a animé très tôt.
Pourquoi l'écriture ? Pourquoi l'enseignement ? Finalement, parce qu'en rentrant des États-Unis, quand j'avais moins d'une trentaine d'années,
j'ai eu un tout petit peu d'avance en termes de connaissances financières et je voulais en faire partager différentes personnes.
Ça a été d'abord des rédactions d'articles, puis de livres et finalement, un doctorat en l'an 2000.
Voilà, c'est une passion, c'est quelque chose que je me suis découvert et j'y consacre toujours beaucoup de temps parce que j'ai toujours un livre en chantier.
Je le disais à l'instant, on sait que l'économie est une science située également. On sait que le monde et son économie ont été fort secoués ces vingt, trente dernières années.
Je pense au hasard à la crise des subprimes. J'aimerais vous demander comment votre perception de l'économie a pu évoluer au cours de ces vingt, trente dernières années.
Elle a fortement évolué parce que j'ai été diplômé en 1984. C'était le début de la période néolibérale. Et donc, pour moi, comme pour mes condisciples d'université, c'était une évidence que le modèle américain
présentait une supériorité en termes d'efficacité incontestable.
Mais, année après année, le temps s'écoulant, la maturité enflant, j'ai commencé à avoir un regard un tout petit peu plus critique sur les choses, peut-être plus tempéré aussi.
Et le krach de 2008 a été une révélation pour moi. Je dirigeais la Bourse à l'époque et avoir vu un système se disloquer, bien que ce soit finalement inhérent à son fonctionnement,
ça m'a interpellé et j'ai eu très rapidement l'intuition que ce krach était plus qu'un ajustement boursier, qu'il emportait des conséquences socio-économiques assez importantes.
Très rapidement, dans les semaines qui ont suivi ce krach, j'ai écrit un livre d'ailleurs, qui s'appelait 2008, l'année du krach.
Et ça m'a conduit à élargir le cercle de mes référents, de rencontrer des ministres, des syndicalistes, des hommes politiques, de faire beaucoup de conférences, d'abord au titre de président de Bourse, mais aussi,
au titre d'acteur, on va dire modique de la vie économique.
Et donc j'ai, je crois, acquis une vision plus tempérée, plus large des choses. Donc c'est le krach qui a été pour moi l'événement fractal, l'événement décisif dans l'évolution de la pensée.
Mh. Et donc aujourd'hui, vous n'êtes plus un grand partisan du capitalisme anglo-saxon néolibéral ?
Je suis un partisan du capitalisme. Je pense qu'il est quasiment l'ordre naturel, l'ordre marchand des sociétés.
Mais par contre, ce qui m'apparaît aujourd'hui, c'est que le néolibéralisme, qui possède une teinte d'anti-étatisme, voire parfois d'anti-social-tiréisme, ne me paraît plus adapté à la gestion des communautés européennes.
Je pense que nous avons tous été
extrêmement influencés par ce modèle américain, promu lui-même par Hollywood et toute une série d'autres médias, sans se rendre compte qu'il était parfois en orthogonalité avec le modèle européen.
Et l'histoire, finalement, c'est que le modèle américain, et j'en parle avec d'autant plus de candeur que ma grand-mère est américaine, que j'ai étudié aux États-Unis, que j'ai travaillé à New York.
Le modèle américain, en fait, est basé sur un phénomène qu'on connaît mal en Europe qui est la mobilité des personnes.
La mobilité est absolue, elle est consubstantielle au modèle américain qui est un pays de pionniers, de découvreurs, hein, partis de l'est vers l'ouest.
Ce sont des personnes qui sont en mouvement perpétuel. Il n'y a pas de tranquillité américaine, il n'y a pas de position stable.
Tout doit être en mouvement, tout est fait pour mettre les personnes en mouvement. Et c'est quelque chose qu'on a beaucoup de mal à comprendre dans nos contrées.
Alors que les États-providence, qu'on connaît en Europe depuis quasiment deux siècles, parce que
finalement, les États-providence ont été les relais pour partie des États-nations, sont fondés sur l'immobilité du travail, puisque dans une vie, il y a une séquence d'abord de réception de biens sociaux.
C'est par exemple l'enseignement. Il y a ensuite des périodes de cotisations d'apports à l'État, on est débiteur de l'État, et puis on redevient créditeur de l'État lorsqu'on bénéficie de retraites, de pensions, de soins de santé.
Et donc, les modèles européens sont basés sur une certaine immobilité du travail qu'ils entretiennent, tandis que les Américains font la promotion de la mobilité du travail.
C'est ça qui m'apparaît aujourd'hui, c'est sans doute une des synthèses importantes. Et quand on a voulu mélanger les deux modèles, on ne s'est pas rendu compte de ces conséquences.
Vous parlez donc de cette évolution que vous avez connue, donc il y a à peu près maintenant une douzaine d'années.
Vous êtes économiste, vous êtes banquier, vous êtes membre, même président du Belgian Finance Club. Est-ce que vous estimez que cette évolution, cette capacité à évoluer, à remettre en question,
vos perceptions, est-ce qu'elle est généralisée dans le milieu ?
Parce qu'on a parfois l'impression que quand on entend certains économistes, que le débat est relativement figé dans le temps et quelque part dans les années septante, dans les années Thatcher et Reagan.
Est-ce que c'est généralisé, ce que vous me racontez ?
La prise de conscience, en tout cas, le regard critique s'amplifie, de la part de personnes qui étaient des zélotes, et j'en ai fait partie, du capitalisme américain néolibéral.
Pourquoi ? Parce que nous vivons un choc, un choc de société, un choc de modèle qui a lui-même été amplifié par des crises comme les gilets jaunes, certains mouvements de contestation sociale.
Et donc, ma quête intellectuelle pour le moment, mais je la partage avec d'autres, c'est le pourquoi, qu'aurions-nous dû comprendre à l'époque ?
Quels sont les traits discriminants des modèles ? Est-ce qu'ils sont conciliables ou pas conciliables
? Et finalement, voilà, ça m'arrive à cette conclusion que la mobilité du travail n'est pas partagée selon les continents.
Puis autre chose qui est assez intéressante, c'est qu'en fait, le modèle américain est basé sur la théorie du ruissellement.
C'est-à-dire qu'on part de l'idée qu'on doit alléger la charge fiscale des personnes les plus nanties-
Mmm-hmm
...pour que cet argent ruisselle vers les personnes qui ont moins de capacités.
Trickle-down economics.
Oui, le trickle-down, au travers, par exemple, de mises à l'emploi. Et donc, ça conduit à diminuer la pression fiscale sur les personnes qui ont des revenus les plus élevés.
Nous avons un système tout à fait différent. Nous taxons de manière progressive
la formation d'épargne. Pourquoi ? Parce que les modèles européens sont basés sur la solidarité, sur, on va dire, la juxtaposition de la contribution du travail et du capital.
Donc, ce sont des modèles extrêmement différents. De plus en plus d'économistes aujourd'hui s'y intéressent. Et Piketty a fait partie des personnes qui ont interpellé l'opinion publique.
J'allais le citer, justement, ouais.
Voilà. Et puis y a surtout l'incontestable augmentation, pas tellement en Europe, mais beaucoup plus ailleurs, des inégalités sociales,
avec une économie de monopole, d'actionnaires, d'entreprises monopolistiques, qui sont devenues extrêmement riches par rapport au reste de l'humanité.
Donc, la configuration du monde a changé et ça va, je crois, créer des frictions sociales, des étincelles sociales qu'on voit déjà apparaître et certaines détonations qui deviennent audibles.
Et donc ça suscite une interrogation, une prise de conscience.
Mmm-hmm. Thomas Piketty qui disait, par exemple
: « La discipline économique n'est toujours pas sortie de sa passion infantile pour les mathématiques et les spéculations purement théoriques, et souvent très idéologiques,
au détriment de la recherche historique et du rapprochement avec les autres sciences sociales. »
Il a raison. Il a raison. Il y a eu toute une école d'économétrie qui s'est développée dans les années cinquante, soixante, septante et un peu plus tard.
Et en fait, Thomas Piketty, contrairement à ce qu'on pense, n'a pas établi une théorie. Il a fait un travail statistique, qui est d'ailleurs quasiment incontestable,
et il a adopté donc une vision empirique, inductive des choses plutôt que déductive.
Je crois que son apport à la science économique est extrêmement important, parce que finalement, les théories économiques sont rares, hein.
Je crois qu'il y en a eu deux essentiellement. Il y a eu Marx, il y a eu Keynes, il y a pas eu grand-chose d'autre.
Et lui, en fait, il a remis les choses en perspective, avec un travail qui est mathématique.
Alors, je l'évoquais tout à l'heure, vous estimez que la monnaie unique dans l'Union européenne a été une erreur. Est-ce que vous pouvez nous en parler ?
La monnaie unique est laid, donc c'est un fait politique comme toute monnaie. C'est laid, est laid pour rester. Mais par contre, je crois que les conditions qui présupposaient son développement n'ont pas été réunies.
C'est d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle les unions monétaires durent un temps limité, quinze, vingt-cinq ans, ça dépend.
Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ? La monnaie unique est née de la réunification allemande. Ça a été une obligation imposée à l'Allemagne d'abandonner sa souveraineté monétaire pour recouvrer sa souveraineté territoriale.
Et rapidement, différents pays se sont joints à cet effort de diplomatie,
avec la conviction que si la monnaie était partagée, toutes les frictions qui étaient envisageables entre les pays, qui avaient conduit d'ailleurs à deux conflits importants en Europe, disparaîtraient.
Le problème, c'est que d'abord, nous n'avons pas d'institutions qui soutiennent suffisamment la monnaie unique. Et d'autre part, cette monnaie unique a été fondée sur la protection du capital et non pas la promotion du travail.
C'est très important parce que ça veut dire que la monnaie a été érigée par un ensemble de principes visant au désendettement des États, à l'équilibre budgétaire, de manière telle que
l'étalon monétaire garde son pouvoir d'achat et que le travail devienne un facteur d'ajustement.
Et c'est d'autant plus paradoxal, voire singulier, que la monnaie unique avait comme condition préalable à son développement la libre circulation des personnes.
Donc, en fait, on a dû établir un postulat de libre circulation des capitaux et des personnes pour pouvoir avoir une monnaie unique.
Mais malheureusement, on n'a pas obtenu la mobilité du travail qu'on aurait pu espérer. C'est pas parce que les personnes sont libres de circuler qu'elles circulent.
Donc en fait, on a créé une monnaie qui était destinée à protéger le capital, une monnaie de thésaurisation,
alors qu'en fait cette monnaie aurait dû être fondée sur la mobilité du travail qui a relevé plutôt de l'ordre du postulat que de la réalité constatée.
Oui, donc vous n'êtes absolument pas en faveur, évidemment, de
du retrait de la monnaie unique, du retrait de l'euro. On observe un peu partout en Europe, par exemple en France, certaines voix qui s'élèvent pour un pédalage en arrière, hein, un retour à l'ancienne monnaie.
Votre vision du projet européen à ce stade, est-ce que vous êtes optimiste ? Est-ce que vous pensez que ça va bien se passer ou est-ce qu'au contraire, vous êtes plutôt apeuré ?
Comme d'autres, je suis interpellé. Je pense que la monnaie unique ne connaîtra pas,
dans les prochaines années, de retour en arrière, parce que tout pays qui déciderait de s'en détacher, un pays de la zone euro, vivrait un phénomène probable
ou d'hyperinflation ou d'hyperréévaluation de la monnaie avec une pulvérisation du système bancaire et donc éventuellement des troubles sociaux.
Donc aujourd'hui, on ne peut pas faire marche arrière. Finalement, si on avait dû faire marche arrière, on aurait dû le faire dès le début et pas vingt ans plus tard.
Maintenant, le projet européen, il est en péril. Des forces centrifuges sont constatées, ne sont pas centripètes.
Et pourquoi ? Parce que l'idée d'avoir un modèle européen cohérent qui avait pu prévaloir au moment de la chute du Mur est un postulat qui ne se vérifie pas.
Donc la nature des orientations, des inflexions politiques est en train de se morceler. On voit d'ailleurs des courants qui correspondent aux vieux courants religieux.
On voit des courants qui sont relatifs à l'inflexion socioculturelle, qui sont en train de se déployer.
Et donc l'Europe devra se réinventer. Et finalement,
la vision la plus homogène et la plus articulée a été celle qui était formulée par Emmanuel Macron, qui avait vu en fait une Europe qui se construise par cercles concentriques, avec
un degré d'échange et de facilitation qui soit d'autant plus important que les pays adhérents soient proches du modèle du cœur de l'Europe.
Et avoir le dernier cercle concentrique qui, par exemple, qui contienne la Turquie et la Russie. Donc un modèle un tout petit peu différent.
On va devoir, je crois, composer avec des orientations différentes dans l'Union européenne.
Oui. Vous évoquiez il y a un instant cette idée qu'il y a des polarités différentes, notamment en ce qui concerne les héritages religieux, protestants et catholiques.
Vous parlez, et vous avez beaucoup parlé dans les ouvrages, je pense, en 2013, des rapports différents à la dette et à l'économie selon ces héritages religieux et culturels.
Il y a, on va dire, la fracture religieuse du XVIᵉ siècle a été quelque chose qui était très très mal étudiée, parce que dans les pays comme la Belgique, d'obédience catholique, ça a été escamoté.
Or, pourtant, c'est un fait majeur que j'ai revisité d'ailleurs sous l'angle de l'économie dans quelques ouvrages.
Et on le sait, hein, la réforme luthérienne d'abord, calviniste aussi, a déthéologisé le temps, le rapport à la monnaie, a rendu théologiquement licite le taux d'intérêt.
Et donc c'est cette réforme, plutôt calviniste que luthérienne d'ailleurs, qui a conduit à l'émergence du progrès.
Max Weber, qui est un sociologue allemand, avait fait une thèse affirmant ou postulant que le contexte protestant avait créé une affinité favorable au développement du capitalisme.
Je crois que sa thèse reste intéressante, mais que finalement, c'est plutôt
le calvinisme qui, partant de Suisse vers les Pays-Bas, l'Angleterre et ensuite les États-Unis, qui a permis de créer une certaine dynamique économique.
C'est un phénomène qui doit être étudié parce que ça suppose que des rapports au temps différents ont dû être établis.
Le modèle catholique étant plutôt un modèle qui part du passé vers le présent, avec le partage de ce qui a été accompli, le modèle protestant étant,
et calviniste étant plutôt un modèle d'anticipation conduisant d'ailleurs au développement des marchés financiers.
Et donc, on remarque encore aujourd'hui, peut-être pas de manière aussi vivace qu'auparavant, que les pays les plus économiquement effervescents sont des pays protestants.
On voit d'ailleurs les... Maintenant évidemment, la question est de savoir : est-ce que ces pays n'ont pas accueilli la réforme parce que cette réforme épousait un contexte préalable ?
C'est possible. On sait que les États-Unis sont un pays d'industriels. Le Royaume-Uni, c'est plutôt un pays de courtiers.
Donc, il y a des différences, mais la réforme a certainement joué un rôle extrêmement important. Le signifiant de la monnaie est différent.
D'ailleurs, dans les pays luthériens, et pas tous, réformés, eh bien, comme l'Allemagne, la dette, ce n'est pas bon.
La dette, c'est le péché, c'est la peine, c'est quelque chose qui doit être évité.
Ça conduit à des économies qui ne veulent pas s'endetter de manière publique, tandis que les pays catholiques sont plutôt des pays au sein desquels la monnaie est utilisée pour établir les rapports sociaux.
Et on voit ça dans la zone euro, hein, dans la zone euro, l'Allemagne, les Pays-Bas, l'Autriche, qui est pourtant catholique, réévalue la monnaie par le travail, par des gains de productivité.
Dans les pays traditionnellement catholiques, la monnaie se dévalue pour le travail, c'est-à-dire pour situer un rapport d'échange acceptable entre le capital et le travail.
Et vous expliquez que ça allait tellement loin que l'Allemagne préférait réévaluer sa monnaie historiquement plutôt que d'accepter une déflation.
Oui, l'Allemagne, en fait, avait cette logique d'avoir une monnaie qui se réévaluait. Et en fait, la réévaluation, c'est pas bon d'un point de vue économique, puisque ça empêche les exportations.
Or, l'Allemagne est un pays qui était exportateur dans différents domaines. Mais l'Allemagne a toujours voulu battre
l'alourdissement de sa monnaie, c'est-à-dire la réévaluation du Deutsche Mark, par une augmentation encore plus importante de la productivité.
Un peu comme quelqu'un qui veut courir plus vite malgré le fait qu'on mette des poids plus importants dans son sac à dos.
Et donc ça a conduit à une logique vertueuse qui elle-même maintenant trouve son aboutissement dans le désendettement structurel de l'Allemagne.
Mmm-hmm. Alors,
j'aimerais faire une transition vers l'actualité peut-être plus récente. On parle beaucoup de la protection de l'environnement et on entend sur les lèvres des plus grands partisans d'un écologisme radical
un blâme très important, des reproches très importants
à notre système capitaliste.
Et on entend même les termes capitalisme et néolibéralisme de manière presque interchangeable. Alors, est-ce que vous pouvez nous rappeler les différences et les définitions de ces notions de capitalisme anglo-saxon-
Oui
...rhénan, libéralisme, néolibéralisme. Est-ce que vous pouvez nous faire une petite cure de rappel sur toutes ces notions ?
Oui, on parle de choses assez différentes hein.
Bien sûr.
Le libéralisme dont les premiers promoteurs ont été Locke, je crois, et Montesquieu, ont préconisé une certaine liberté d'entreprendre, un peu comme Adam Smith.
Le néolibéralisme a été théorisé pour la première fois au milieu du XIXe siècle avec l'idée qu'en fait, chacun avait un droit de désobéir à l'État si l'État était trop intrusif dans la vie des gens.
Et donc ça a conduit à des logiques antiétatiques, antisociales. Finalement, maintenant, on parle de néolibéralisme pour faire une scission entre la période pré-Thatcher/Reagan et la période post-Thatcher/Reagan.
Je pense qu'on vit maintenant avec Trump une amplification du libéralisme encore plus importante que ce qu'on a pu constater dans les années 80.
Mais donc voilà, ça part de l'idée qu'en fait,
le capital doit prévaloir sur le travail, et qu'en fait le travail doit, dans une logique d'intranquillité, de mouvement quasiment brownien, s'adapter au capital.
C'est la théorie de l'offre de l'école de Chicago. C'est elle-même qui est un produit dérivé de l'école du Mont-Pèlerin de 1947, qui avait en fait été façonnée par différentes personnes qui voulaient absolument,
redonner à l'économie spontanée ses lettres de noblesse.
Le capitalisme, c'est autre chose. C'est, selon l'acception traditionnelle, la propriété privée des moyens de production.
C'est, selon Keynes, un rapport structurant entre le salariat et le capital.
Et je pense qu'on peut très bien avoir un système capitaliste qui ne soit pas néolibéral,
puisque la propriété privée des moyens de production ne suppose pas que les rapports sociaux soient laissés eux-mêmes, c'est-à-dire sans régulation étatique ou en tout cas sans tempérance collective.
Et on dit ça qu'effectivement, le capitalisme
néolibéral, le néolibéralisme anglo-saxon et le capitalisme rhénan,
rhénan qui vient du Rhin, c'est en fait une école
qui est elle-même fondée sur l'ordo-libéralisme, théorie dans les années 30, qui partait de l'idée que l'économie devait avoir un certain degré de spontanéité, mais que tout cela devait être ordonnancé par des pouvoirs publics.
C'est d'ailleurs un système dans lequel l'Allemagne est toujours maintenant immergée, avec on va dire une convergence d'intérêts entre le capital et le travail, dans un esprit qui lui-même, je crois,
découle un tout petit peu du luthéranisme.
Donc, on parle de choses assez différentes. Et ce que nous n'avons pas compris en Europe, c'est ça le message le plus important, c'est que le néolibéralisme américain n'était pas cohérent avec la notion d'État-providence, dans--
État-providence essentiellement construit dans les années
40, dans la logique de Beveridge,
cet économiste anglais qui, en 42 ou 43, avait fait un rapport assez décisif.
On a cru pouvoir bénéficier des avantages de la logique anglo-saxonne, américaine essentiellement, tout en gardant nos États-providence.
Mais finalement, ce n'est pas possible puisque l'orthogonalité, l'antagonisme entre les deux, c'est la mobilité du travail qui est exigée par le néolibéralisme américain et qui est en fait inhibée par l'État-providence.
Mh. Donc, pour de nouveau citer Thomas Piketty qui disait
: « Si le retour sur le capital est, disons, 5 % par an, alors que l'économie croît de, disons, 3 % par an, c'est-à-dire que le capital s'accroît plus vite que l'économie, alors les détenteurs du capital
s'approprient une part plus importante de l'économie chaque année, ce qui est recette de l'inégalité.
» Et donc on a, de nouveau, pour reciter, voilà, ce discours montant chez les écologistes, dans le capitalisme, un rapport d'oppression inhérent et des inégalités inhérentes.
Est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ça ?
Oui, oui, puisque le,
puisque le capital est plus-- d'abord, le capital s'extrait du travail hein. Comme disait Karl Marx, le capital est un quantum, une partie de travail, et que dès que le capital s'est extrait du travail, il est plus mobile
que le travail qui garde une certaine spatio-temporalité.
Et donc, naturellement, dès le moment où le capital a été formulé, en fait, quand on est sorti du système féodal,
dès le moment où la monnaie a servi à être de rémunération du
travail tout en étant utilisée pour concentrer le capital et créer des manufactures, on a créé bien sûr deux facteurs de production avec des rythmes différents.
C'est évident. On a d'ailleurs oublié que la terre, qui est un troisième facteur de production, avait des ressources limitées alors qu'on les croyait illimitées.
Et donc oui, il y a un rapport d'oppression entre les deux, ça n'a jamais été contesté. D'ailleurs, ça avait conduit Karl Marx
à cette fameuse sentence qui clôture le Manifeste du Parti communiste en disant : « Prolétaires de tous les pays, unissez-vous », parce qu'il avait compris que
comme le travail était plus immobile, il fallait qu'il soit coordonné, qu'il soit uni pour pouvoir s'opposer à un capital qui lui-même était mondialisé, était globalisé.
Et en fait, on sera toujours dans une domination du capital sur le travail pour cette question de mobilité accrue du capital par rapport au travail.
Donc, vous opposez à ce néolibéralisme une politique de grands projets industriels à l'échelle européenne, donc une politique plutôt keynésienne.
Est-ce que vous l'observez aujourd'hui, cette politique keynésienne ? Est-ce que vous l'observez en Europe, en Belgique, à l'échelle mondiale, quelque part ?
Mais c'est-à-dire que bizarrement, la logique keynésienne est plutôt appliquée dans des pays qui se disent non keynésiens, c'est-à-dire le Royaume-Uni, on le verra bientôt, les États-Unis, où
les investissements publics sont beaucoup plus régaliens qu'on a pu l'imaginer, la Chine évidemment.
Tandis que dans les pays qui auraient dû pouvoir se prévaloir du keynésianisme, comme les pays d'Europe occidentale, on se rend compte que les investissements publics sont quasiment réduits à néant.
Prenez le cas de la Belgique, ils représentent à peu près 5 % du budget de l'État, c'est-à-dire pas grand-chose.
Et en fait, on devrait retrouver la logique keynésienne, mais malheureusement, celle-ci est inhibée, est empêchée par les règles de fonctionnement de l'euro qui ne font pas la distinction
suffisante entre les dépenses d'investissement et les dépenses de fonctionnement et qui
interdisent aux États de s'endetter, malgré que le taux d'intérêt soit nul, voire négatif,
pour mettre en œuvre des investissements productifs et créateurs d'emplois dans tous les domaines, hein, que ce soit dans le domaine de la logistique, des transports, de la transition climatique.
Donc, en fait, on devrait retrouver Keynes, mais voilà, le problème, c'est que l'euro a créé une prison, une prison d'ailleurs en termes de postulat, en termes de comportement
qui n'est malheureusement pas adapté à la peine que l'économie doit subir pour le moment.
Pour revenir sur la notion du climat, la question de la protection de l'environnement,
il y a une question philosophique plus large qui est de savoir si le capitalisme est le système économique qui nous permettra d'affronter, de résoudre les problématiques qui sont liées à la sauvegarde de l'environnement.
Est-ce que c'est le bon système ?
Oui, je pense qu'on a des défis climatiques, environnementaux extrêmement, extrêmement importants. On fait violence à la nature, finalement.
Et ce qui pose problème, c'est que le coût des externalités, c'est-à-dire des dommages ultérieurs, n'est pas assez incorporé dans les prix de marché.
Ce sera finalement la rareté des biens publics, de l'eau, de l'oxygène, qui vont entraîner des modifications du prix.
Moi, je crois qu'il faut voir l'économie de marché et la vision étatique comme étant l'avers et le revers d'une même médaille, c'est-à-dire qu'il faut l'un et l'autre.
D'ailleurs, Adam Smith, qui est le premier penseur du
libéralisme économique, n'avait rien dit d'autre en insistant sur le rôle régulateur de l'État, qui doit jouer un rôle de tempérance par rapport aux forces furieuses du capitalisme.
Donc, je crois, oui, je crois au capitalisme. Je crois que c'est une,
ça a une émulation, une innovation, ça porte même la démocratie dans beaucoup de contextes, mais qu'il faut un État qui soit un contrepouvoir dans le cas de dérapage.
Alors, on parle de politique keynésienne, on parle d'un État-providence qui regagne une importance pour, voilà, répondre à ces problématiques-là.
Et donc, vous parliez à l'instant de démocratie. Ça demande des solutions intelligentes qui viennent du monde politique, qui sont soutenues par le peuple.
Or, nous voyons ces dernières années une montée de populisme et de solutions très dangereuses qui sont présentées à la fois, donc soutenues à la fois par certaines parties de la population et certains politiciens.
Ça traduit finalement un sentiment d'abandon de la part de ces populations.
Oui, il y a-- Une fois qu'on est rentré dans une logique d'efficience des services publics, ça conduit à l'abandon de transports publics, à la précarisation des écoles.
Ça soumet tous ces biens publics à des logiques d'efficience et de rentabilité qui ne sont pas adaptées.
Finalement, on fait une erreur complète en croyant qu'un État se gère comme une entreprise. Et que l'entreprise, selon Schumpeter, et il a raison d'ailleurs, est à la recherche du monopole éphémère, tandis que
l'État doit gérer des valeurs morales pour commencer
et un certain apaisement social.
Et en fait, le populisme, c'est quoi ? C'est en fait la rancœur de populations qui, je crois en partie légitimement, se sentent abandonnées par les États qui ne les protègent plus,
États qui sont eux-mêmes écartelés entre ces populations mécontentes et des marchés qui leur échappent.
Et donc, ça crée une tension très très importante avec un message qui, finalement, de la part de tous ces populistes, est plus ou moins cohérent, qu'il soit de gauche ou de droite, c'est-à-dire
recouvrer des transferts sociaux, des biens publics de qualité,
et en même temps, malheureusement, rendre l'économie un peu plus isolationniste.
Parce que bien sûr, il y a cette phobie de la peur de l'étranger qui est invoquée. Mais on peut comprendre cette peur de l'étranger, bien qu'elle ne soit économiquement pas justifiée.
Parce que quand on dit à un travailleur : « Tu sais, ton entreprise va déménager à l'autre bout du monde », c'est du capital qui s'exporte, il perd son travail.
Il a l'impression que si un étranger vient, il va aussi perdre son travail parce qu'il sera moins disant d'un point de vue social.
Mais si je mets de côté cet argument qui n'est pas correct, on le sait,
ce populisme-- Et en plus, je n'aime pas tellement le mot populisme parce que je trouve qu'il est un, bien que c'était le titre d'un de mes ouvrages, mais-
Oui
...c'est un peu, mais c'est un-- J'ai pris des précautions en l'utilisant. C'est un titre, un mot un peu méprisant parce que ça donne l'impression que le peuple a tort contre des élites qui penseraient mieux que lui.
Oui, Emmanuel Macron dit ça aussi, oui.
Voilà. Mais donc, c'est en fait une inquiétude. D'ailleurs, on voit bien que ce populisme
s'est développé dans des zones périurbaines, s'est développé auprès de personnes qui avaient perdu les solidarités.
C'est d'ailleurs très frappant de lire, je l'ai, comme vous sans doute, vu récemment,
qu'un des principaux arguments sociologiques qui avait été invoqué comme facteur de mal-vivre de la part de personnes qui avaient participé au mouvement des gilets jaunes, c'était l'absence de supérette.
Donc en fait l'absence de lieux, de lieux communs.
Mh.
Et d'ailleurs, ça me fait penser que si la révolution industrielle a permis de transformer le colporteur en boutiquier, aujourd'hui, ben Internet démantèle le boutiquier pour en faire des colporteurs digitaux, hein.
Et donc voilà, il y a des manques de transport en commun. Il y a ce sentiment d'injustice, d'opposition des zones on va dire un peu éloignées par rapport aux centres urbains.
Et tout ça, ça montre que l'État a un rôle à jouer, un rôle de tempérance, un rôle de développement économique et qu'on ne peut pas uniquement soumettre un État à d'énormes déficiences et d'efficacité capitalistes.
Je le répète, on ne peut pas gérer un État comme une entreprise.
Oui. Et vous expliquez justement dans ce dernier ouvrage que les réactions populistes dont nous parlions à l'instant et le capitalisme anglo-saxon, en fait, s'entretiennent.
Oui, ils s'entretiennent parce que le capitalisme anglo-saxon est un capitalisme d'exploitation qui veut absolument faire du travailleur, du consommateur, de l'homo economicus,
un, oui, un consommateur, c'est-à-dire quelqu'un qui va utiliser ses derniers euros pour, dans un acte commercial.
Tandis que le travailleur, épuisé par l'absence d'épargne et la fragilité de son pouvoir d'achat, est fâché contre les États qui ne le protègent pas.
Et donc on a une triangulation
malsaine entre, d'une part, un modèle économique qu'on veut imposer et qui relève, je disais, du néolibéralisme
anglo-saxon, des États qui ne sont plus capables de protéger leur population et parfois qui ne le font pas assez,
et ces mêmes populations qui sont elles-mêmes en amertume des biens sociaux qu'on leur a promis et qui ne seront sans doute pas honorés.
Mmh.
Le projet européen, allez, oui, donc à l'échelle de l'Europe,
qui est le fruit d'une réflexion des élites, qui est très abstrait, qui s'oppose finalement à une logique de l'humus des peuples pour qui il est beaucoup plus logique d'aller vers une logique de nationalisme.
Est-ce que de par sa fragilité, la fragilité de ce projet européen qui n'est pas intuitif, est-ce qu'on ne va pas inévitablement vers un projet qui est amené à s'autodétruire ?
Oui, la notion d'humus des peuples, ça vient d'une phrase que Stefan Zweig avait écrite en 1936. Je ne sais pas.
Je ne sais pas. Je ne sais pas dans quelle mesure le sentiment européen n'est pas un sentiment artificiel qui est lui-même la résultante de-- oui, un sentiment construit, qui est la résultante
du fait qu'il a failli faire la paix entre des pays qui partageaient des frontières communes.
Et, oui, certains sont un peu pessimistes. Je le suis moins parce que je crois que tous les Européens veulent un mode de comportement tempéré
et que la facilité de transport, d'échange d'idées a conduit à, on va dire, éroder les aigreurs de certains.
Mais, sous l'angle institutionnel, les choses ne sont pas claires. On voit d'ailleurs très très bien que le couple franco-allemand, qui était à la base de la reconstruction européenne d'après-guerre, est un couple qui ne s'entend plus bien.
On peut pas dire qu'il est en train de divorcer, mais il ne s'entend plus bien. Et que voilà, les trames de pensée sont parfois très très opposées.
Mmh mmh. Et vous parlez même d'un glissement d'un monde aux racines catholiques vers un contexte d'empreinte protestante.
Oui, le modèle néolibéral est de manière très très très lointaine, d'obédience protestante, calviniste, comme je le disais.
Mmh mmh.
Le modèle catholique qui a fondé l'État-providence est aujourd'hui fragilisé par ces courants de commerce. J'avais d'ailleurs consacré il y a quelques années un livre où je parlais de l'influence de Calvin sur l'économie européenne.
Je le maintiens. Je crois que la réforme calviniste est peut-être en train de revenir par un mode de pensée qui n'en porte plus, bien sûr, le nom, mais qui est peut-être incontestable.
Oui. Et donc, pour revenir sur cette polarité protestant et catholique, est-ce que ça explique en partie le rapport, le rapport particulier qu'ont les Français à l'argent, à l'opulence ?
Oui, sans doute. Le rapport à l'argent, c'est plutôt le rapport à la collectivité qu'à l'argent.
Le signifiant de la monnaie est différent dans les pays réformés et les pays catholiques, mais il est évident que
dans les pays catholiques, comme le riche ne pouvait pas plaire à Dieu, il fallait l'écarter, d'où la négation du taux d'intérêt, d'où
la vision, on va dire, égalitariste de la société, tandis que dans certains pays protestants, mais qui ont dérivé de la réforme, hein, pour devenir beaucoup plus anglo-saxons,
on promeut la richesse avec un système de pensée qui est très différent. Absolument.
Oui. Alors, nous allons bientôt devoir nous quitter puisque vous êtes un homme très occupé. Quelques questions rapides pour clôturer.
La Belgique est un pays où le patrimoine individuel est en moyenne, en général, très important. Selon les classements qu'on consulte, c'est soit premier, soit dans les premiers.
Donc beaucoup d'argent en banque, a priori.
Oui.
Cet argent qui reste en banque, est-ce qu'il est utile pour l'économie ? Est-ce que certains disent qu'il faut le taxer, taxer les milliardaires, taxer les millionnaires.
J'ai-- Je ne me prononcerai pas sur la taxation, mais cet argent n'est pas inutile. Cet argent, il est recyclé au travers des bilans bancaires vers des prêts à l'économie publique, à l'économie privée.
Donc c'est un recyclage permanent. Cet argent serait
inutile, serait stérilisé s'il était investi, par exemple, sous forme de billets ou de lingots, ou que sais-je, de manière improductive dans un coffre, ce qui n'est pas le cas.
Donc, il y a un roulement naturel de la monnaie. Mais c'est vrai que ce roulement,
mais ça, c'est plutôt lié au contexte européen, au contexte qui frôle la récession, ce flux monétaire n'est pas utilisé de manière assez active.
Donc, il n'y a pas une traction naturelle de la demande et de l'investissement qui mette en mouvement cette monnaie, mais donc la monnaie créée est recyclée, bien sûr, dans les bilans des banques et des compagnies d'assurance.
Mmh. Une autre idée dont on parle beaucoup à l'échelle européenne, c'est la notion de banque centrale du climat. Est-ce que ce serait une solution ?
Oui, ce serait une solution intéressante.
Et comment ça fonctionnerait ?
Eh bien, on pourrait très très bien imaginer de créer une banque centrale du climat qui soit une banque centrale, ou une quasi banque centrale, ça pourrait être
adossée à la BCE, ça pourrait être adossée à la Banque européenne d'investissement, qui puisse réescompter contre des euros sonnants et trébuchants des emprunts publics ou privés destinés à la transition climatique.
C'est une idée qui avait été formulée par Pierre Larrouturou, qui est un économiste français. J'avais d'ailleurs été le rencontrer, avec lui, Charles Michel quand il était encore Premier ministre en Belgique, avant les élections du mois de mai.
Et c'est quelque chose qui a du sens. Et j'ai l'impression que,
Christine Lagarde, présidente de la BCE, va certainement s'emparer de l'idée,
puisque la Banque centrale européenne peut décider des critères de qualification ou de réescompte des emprunts publics ou privés dans le bilan de la BCE.
Donc pourquoi pas, et finalement profiter de ce nouveau créancier qui s'appelle une banque centrale et qui peut en plus acheter de l'argent à taux extrêmement réduits pour financer cette transition climatique.
On parle d'un montant qui pourrait atteindre deux mille milliards d'euros sur une période de dix à quinze ans, c'est-à-dire quand même 20 % du PIB européen, de la zone euro d'une année.
Donc c'est intéressant. Vous dites, Christine Lagarde serait, d'après vos impressions, plutôt enthousiaste par rapport à ce projet-là.
Je crois qu'elle n'y est pas opposée parce que—
C'est autre chose.
Je ne vois pas. Non, mais on sait pas. D'ailleurs, les banquiers centraux sont des gens extrêmement discrets et prudents, mais on ne peut pas imaginer qu'à un moment, la réflexion ne
n'effleure pas les instances dirigeantes européennes, sachant que nous avons mis en œuvre maintenant depuis cinq, six ans, une création monétaire sans précédent.
Cette création monétaire a été garantie par des emprunts d'État essentiellement, mais des emprunts d'État dont la contrepartie sont des dépenses de fonctionnement ou du refinancement des États.
On pourrait imaginer d'avoir une tranche de réescompte pour des emprunts spécifiquement orientés vers la transition climatique.
Oui, c'est envisageable.
Mmh. Donc il s'agirait là alors d'un, quelque part
d'un de ces grands projets keynésiens industriels à l'échelle européenne qui permettrait de s'opposer aux grandes problématiques du néolibéralisme que vous évoquiez et aussi de participer à la sauvegarde de l'environnement.
Oui.
Très bien. On est enthousiaste alors. Une autre question rapide que je voulais poser. Quand on parlait des problématiques liées au capitalisme anglo-saxon, il y a toujours la question de la spéculation qui revient.
Est-ce que vous seriez en faveur de l'interdiction, de la pénalisation de la spéculation ?
C'est une idée de mon ami Paul Jorion, avec qui j'ai souvent animé des conférences et coécrit un livre.
C'est très compliqué de qualifier la spéculation. Tout est spéculation. Quand j'achète une action, une obligation, j'espère que sa valeur va monter, donc je spécule.
J'oppose mon anticipation à celle d'un autre qui croit que ça va baisser.
Si on parle plus spécifiquement alors de la vente, du short sell à court terme.
Oui, mais c'est aussi un débat compliqué. Finalement, on ne peut vendre que ce qu'on possède. Donc on peut démontrer sous l'angle mathématique que c'est un jeu finalement à somme nulle entre un acheteur et un vendeur.
Donc toute la difficulté provient de la qualification de la spéculation. Or, la plupart des actes que nous posons sont des actes de maximisation d'utilité.
Et dans le domaine concret, on va dire, de l'augmentation de la, de la baisse de valeurs mobilières, eh bien, on achète parce qu'on croit que ça va monter.
Donc on spécule à la hausse, tandis que le vendeur vend parce qu'il croit que ça va baisser, donc il spécule à la baisse.
Et donc c'est extrêmement compliqué de pouvoir qualifier une transaction selon les anticipations, les intuitions qui animent les différents opérateurs.
Donc, je comprends l'idée sous l'angle sémantique. Je la dissèque beaucoup moins sous l'angle pratique.
Ça vous semble difficilement implémentable. Bruno Colmant, merci beaucoup pour ces quarante minutes passées ensemble.
Merci beaucoup. En tout cas, c'est un grand plaisir. Et puis j'espère surtout que,
que vos auditeurs auront envie de peut-être se réinformer, parce que
le but n'est pas simplement de m'écouter, mais de susciter la réflexion, l'intuition, la contradiction et, voilà, j'espère que ces quelques propos vont essaimer
et susciter, comme je disais, la curiosité.
Merci beaucoup en tout cas.
Merci beaucoup. Au revoir. Voilà, comme annoncé, c'est un épisode qui est plus court que d'habitude. J'en suis désolé. N'hésitez pas à me dire ce que vous en avez pensé.
Pour ça, vous pouvez me contacter via les réseaux sociaux. Tous les liens sont dans la description. Et n'oubliez pas de parler du podcast autour de vous.
À très bientôt. Salut !